good morning believe nation today's
message is replaced failure with
feedback over to you Peter Jones I wake
up every morning in espresso TV go I
mean I've got a real belief and this is
a true belief and if those of you
everybody's got kids out there if I ever
hear my kids say the word failure I lock
them in a room for a week and I i would
request if we have any power in this
country that we could take that out of
our english dictionary and replace it
with the word feedback yeah because
that's all failure in our word caesars
never its feedback we learn from mistake
when I was growing up my parents used to
tell me Evan Arrakis Trilly Carmichael
and you can do whatever you want I
remember when report cards season came
around it was always expected that we
would get ease and my sister is both of
them always got aids and here i was i
was getting B's and C's and he said hate
report card season because I'd have to
sit down with my parents go over my
report cards and I wasn't meeting their
expectations but instead of chewing me
out they always told me that I was a
cost rlly Carmichael and that I could do
it and that they believed in me and that
formed what I believe the foundation of
belief for me right I have
self-confidence and I believe in myself
even when I wasn't getting the results I
still believe that I could do better and
I could reach for those results I've
continued that tradition on with my son
Hayden is six and we have this thing
that we do a couple of times a week were
will say I'm hating Carmichael and I can
do anything and I'll usually started off
and i say i'm hating carmichael and i
can do and then he'll go anything
because i want to continue that
tradition of belief and self-confidence
because i want to be the person that
helps build others up and lets them
believe in their dreams and try to help
them move towards it not the person who
tears people down and is that why don't
you be realistic guy why don't you do
something that you're capable of guy the
you can never do that
guy that'd be practical guy I don't want
to be that guy that's the little man
those are the dream Squasher 'he's and
my intention is not just to bring it to
my son the next generation but also to
spread it out to the world to share it
with you guys is why I started this
YouTube channel why I'm still so
dedicated to making videos because I
want you to believe in yourself because
I want you to go and create something
amazing and not be surrounded by a
negative environment that holds you back
because I want you to have a bigger
dream and to believe that it's possible
to take action every day that move
closer towards it failure is just a form
of feedback there are some people who
fail and they fail once and then they
live the rest of their lives through the
lens of failure because they failed once
it means they can never have success
doing something and so they're just
going to take the safe route and on top
of that on top of living a meteoric
alive themselves they have to suck other
people down with them right you have a
big idea that you want to go and take
off and change the world now you can't
do that I tried doing something that
didn't work you're just gonna fail don't
do it right they create this black hole
that just sucks negativity in chances
are you know somebody like that so
failure is just feedback failure is a
way to know how not to do something the
next time it makes you smarter it gives
you more resourceful pneus it gives you
more ideas so that when you attack litig
n you'll do it differently this time if
you show me any successful entrepreneur
any successful person in whatever field
you'll find that they failed and they
failed and they failed and they failed
and then they succeed you fail your way
to success you get the feedback on how
not to do it you try it again a
different way you try it again a
different way you try to get a different
way and then you hit it that's how you
achieve success so stop seeing failure
as this final thing that because it
happened once you're never going to be
successful failure is just feedback
believe so the question that a 10 a is
I'm curious to learn what are some of
the most important lessons that you've
learned from failing what
have you learned that I've made you a
better person about a human being I
better entrepreneur sharing the comments
below I'm really curious to find out I
think it could also help a lot of people
watching this video as well so leave in
the comments below thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events vessel